حضرت نائبه الامين العام للامم المتحده
مينا محمد عبر الجزيره اثناء جوله افريقيه
لها من تداعيات القرار موسكو تجميد العمل
باتفاق نقل الحبوب كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا
ونناقشه في مسارات ثلاثه منعكاسات ازمه
تجميد اتفاق نقل الحبوب على الامن الغذائي
العالمي وما هي الخيارات المطروحه على
الدول التي راعت من قبل ذلك الاتفاق كيف
للامم المتحده ان تتعامل مع تداعيات هذه
الازمه
[موسيقى]
الامن الغذائي في العالم اساسا يعاني نقص
الكميات الغذاء سواء كانت قمح او الحبوب
او البذور الزيتيه جاءت لتساهم بارتفاع
غير مسبوق في عالم في عالم الغذاء وهذا
الارتفاع طبعا يؤثر بشكل مباشر على الدول
ذات الدخل المنخفض سوف نشهد ارتفاع في
نسبه انعدام الامن الغذائي وانتشار نقص
التغذيه روسيا فعلا من اتفاقيه الحبوب فقط
لان
الواجبات التي التي كان من المفروض ان
تقوم بها الدول الغربيه اتجاه روسيا هذه
الواجبات لم تنفذ قد تكون روسيا مذنبه في
ان بعض الدول في اسيا او افريقيا سوف
تتعرض للجوع هذا تفسير غير سليم لان روسيا
تقوم بعروض انسانيه وتقديم الحبوب بالمجان
وايصالها لاي شعب من الشعوب المحتاجه واضح
جدا للعالم الان بان روسيا غير مهتمه ولا
تريد تقديم الطعام وسالم من الغذاء
والسلامه للعالم لو كانت بكل بساطه فقط
توقف الاتفاق الخاص في نقل الحبوب من
الموانع الاوكرانيه
فان ذلك بحد ذاته يمكن يعتبر جريمه كبيره
الانسانيه ولكن بعد ذلك فورا بعد هذا
قاموا بقصف المنشات
الميناء
والمعدات اللازمه لتحميل
المواد الغذائيه او الحبوب على السفن هذا
يبين ان تحديده قدراته اوكرانيا على دعم
احتياجات الدول الاكثر فقرا في العالم
الذين يحتاجون المزيد من
الحبوب الحديث عن
ان المناطق التي تتحدث عنها اوكرانيا بل
تقصف المستودعات والمصانع حيث تصنع
الاسلحه
وليس بهدف حرق الحبوب خط نقل غاز الامونيا
من تولياتي في روسيا الى اوديسا في
اوكرانيا ليصدر ثلاث ملايين طن في العالم
هذا الخط اساسا متوقف عن العمل منذ بدايه
الحرب فبالتالي ضرب او لم يضرب لا يؤثر
على تصدير هذه الغازات وايضا كيف سوف تقوم
الناقلات الخطره بحمل غاز الامونيا
بالدخول الى اوديسيا ونقل هذه
المكونات الخطره في منطقه تقريبا شبع حروف
توقع ان يتم العوده الى هذا الاتفاق قد
تكون ببعض الشروط المعدله قد تكون ببعض
الشروط المشروطه على سبيل المثال يتم
الاتفاق على رفع القيود حول بنك الزراعي
اهم جزء فيما ما نواجههم المشكله حاليا
هو ان روسيا غزت اوكرانيا لو انها سحبت
قواته من اوكرانيا موجب اتفاقيه التي وقعت
منذ زمن بعيد لما واجهنا هذه المشكله
العالم يريد القمح سواء كان اوكرانيا او
روسيا لذلك انا عندما اتخلى عن السياسه
والتزم باخلاق الانسانيه يجب ان اسمح
بوصول القمح
الروسي والاوكراني الى الجياع في العالم
روسيا مستعده كمساعده انسانيه دون اي ثمن
ان تقدم حبوبها للدول الفقيره في افريقيا
وفي اسيا هذا كاثبات لحسن النوايا كشريك
مسؤول روسيا مستعده ان تقوم بهذا وهذا هو
الموقف الرسمي في روسيا وبهذه الطريقه من
المستحيل ان نتهم روسيا باي شيء فقط لمجرد
تجميدها
للاتفاق حتى تستمر اوكرانيا بتصدير حبوب
الذرر
البقيه تمت بين الامم المتحده وتركيا وبين
ومع روسيا واوكرانيا كل على حدى ما قامت
به الامم المتحده في الاتفاق مع روسيا لم
يكن
التعهد برفع هذه هو التعهد على العمل لرفع
هذه القيود لسبب بسيط لانه من وضع هذه
القيود سواء قيود
الاسود او الدعم المصرفي او التامين او
غيرها هي الدول الغربيه فليست الامم
المتحده وليست تركيا فلذلك هي لا تملك حق
ان تعطي الالتزام برفع هذه البنود بينما
العمل على ذلك وهي تعمل على ذلك منذ العام
تقريبا وتحاول